[Music]
[Applause]
that day on the beach it changed it you
want revenge what you think you're gonna
jump from cell-to-cell taking out
terrorists for starters yeah our people
here like your agenda image I know
exactly what to do with you
[Music]
what I need to know about this guy he's
a warrior one of the best I've ever
known so that you don't you now you want
to go kill terrorists am i right out
there it's about the mission not about
you sigh cement stroke right here like
this he's testing through the roof you
need to focus is off the charts I've
seen off the charts before not like this
you think you're special never ever let
it get personal what is it you think we
do here young people need to be killed
we got a problem six days ago 15 kilos
of plutonium went missing look at this
can't be him it's him I read it's ghost
why is this guy after you some personal
something everything he did
there's a [ __ ] nuke in place
go 48 Sistani
I trusted you you should have come for
me eliminate the target yes sir
[Music]
where's your team
[Music]
this whole thing is just a mean stone
entry even now this is just a beginning
[Music]
you